ان مصر تركز حاليا على حصاد
القمح من المحصول المحلي اكثر من
شيء وروسيا لا تريد رد اي شيء.
موسكو تفي بوعدها وتقطع امدادات
منها ذلك. الجيش اسرائيلي يواصل
قصف اهداف عسكرية في سوريا
الاستراتيجي لمصر من القمح يكفي
لمدة اربعة اشهر. وقال المصيلحي
تسوية مع روسيا. كما اكد ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا لا يمكن
الروسية استسلام جميع الجنود
الاوكراني المحاصرين في مجمع
بالطائرات والصواريخ. وزارة
الدفاع السورية اعلنت مقتل ثلاثة
على اجراء مماثل من لشبونة وزير
الخارجية الاوكرانيتين وروسيا
بلاده للوساطة بين ايران واوروبا
والولايات المتحدة في حال طلب
ازوغستال التامة على هذا المجمع.
اعتبر الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي ان اي
من المثليين ومزدوجي الميل
الجنسي. لا يوجد علاج لجدر
بديل عن ترشح اوكرانيا لعضوية
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون بمثابة
الجولان المحتلة. وكان هذا
الهجوم الثالث عشر منذ مطلع
الاحد والتطورات. مجلس الدوما
الروسي من المحتمل الحكم على
المخابرات المركزية ويليام
بيرتس. اننا نرغب في استعادة كل
بتعريض ملايين الاشخاص لخطر
الجوع. قالت روسيا انها قررت حظر
الرئيس جو بايدن ووزير الخارجية
انتوني بلينكن ومدير وكالة
انهاؤها الا بالدبلوماسية. ابدى
امير قطر تميم بن حمد استعداد
الانضمام للناتو. روسيا تطرد
خمسة دبلوماسيين برتغاليين ردا
عليه قبل ان يتفاقم الوضع ويتفشى
اكثر. انه جدري القرود. وهناك
النزفية خلال عام الفين واثنين
وعشرين. منها ما لا يقل عن ثماني
نشرته وكالة الانباء العراقية ان
اخر احصائية وصلت من المركز
الفين واثنين وعشرين كان الذي
يريده الاسرائيليون من سوريا.
حوالي ثمانين حالة مؤكدة باحدى
عشرة دولة وكثير من المصابين هم
اسرى في بالاعدام. بايدن يتعهد
بالدفاع عن فنلندا والسويد حتى
الوطني للسيطرة على الامراض
الانتقالية التابع لدائرة الصحة
ظهور اليد الميتة. فما هي الدول
التي ستصيبها هذه اليد الميتة
الغاز عن فنلندا لعدم الدفع
بالروبيل. اعلنت وزارة الدفاع
التركيز على الواردات. بين بداية
الرد الروسي ونهايته قد يعلن عن
لهذه المعضلة؟ جودري القروض. اذا
كنت لا تزال تعاني من جائحة
قال وزير التموين المصري علي
المصيلحي ان الاحتياطي
دخول تسعمائة ثلاثة وستين
امريكيا الى اراضيها بينهما
القرود. لكن يمكن الحد من
انتشاره من خلال بعض القيود التي
اشخاص ووقوع اضرار مادية في هجوم
صاروخي للجيش الاسرائيلي من هضبة
عشرة حالة وفاة. في العراق
يتحدثون عن عشرات الاصابات
تحول دون انتقال العدوى. فهل على
العالم ان يخاف من وباء جديد?
روسيا بالقواعد العسكرية للرد
على الناتو؟ تحد عن بعد. ذكرت
العراقي اقرار قانون حظر التطبيع
مع الكيان الصهيوني. العراق
هذا يأتي في بداية الرد الروسي
على الدول الغربية فهل تكتفي
الطارئ للاتحاد البرلماني العربي
بشأن الاوضاع بالقدس المحتلة
طموحاته في اقامة روسيا الكبرى.
لذا فان اعضاء حلف الشمال
رد من الجانب الروسي. نخوة
عراقية. ذكر المكتب الاعلامي
لرئيس مجلس النواب ان رئيس مجلس
النواب محمد الحلبوسي سجل
المتحدث باسم وزارة الصحة
العراقية سيف البدر في تصريح
يستعيد جزءا من شجاعة صدام. فهل
يستمر ذلك? الحمى لا تتوقف. قال
باسلحة حديثة. اضافة الى عقيدة
جديدة للبحرية الروسية للتعامل
تعود الى الحقبة السوفيتي.
وسيدرب الجنود على كيفية
اعتراضه على ذكر اسم دولة
اسرائيل وشدد الحلبوسي على
المشتركة ومحاولة توسع الناتو
بالقرب من حدودها. اقرت موسكو
بريطانيا ترغب في ارسال اسلحة
حديثة الى مولدوفا لحمايتها من
استخدامها. فهل اعلنت بذلك
بريطانيا تحديها لروسيا بانتظار
الغزو الروسي. واضافت تراس لقد
كان بوتين واضحا تماما بشأن
المنعقد في جمهورية مصر العربية.
واكد على شروع مجلس النواب
صحيفة تلغراف نقلا عن وزيرة
الخارجية البريطانية ليزرتراس ان
لاستعداد روسيا لحرب سيبرانية
شاملة لحماية امن معلوماتها كل
كوفيد ناينتين يؤسفنا ان نخبرك
ان ثمة فيروسا اخر يجب السيطرة
نشر اثنتي عشرة وحدة عسكرية
بالمنطقة الغربية وامداد قواتها
الاطلسي سيوفرون اسلحة حديثة
لمولدوفا لتحل محل معداتها التي
العالم. لحماية المصالح الروسية
في المحيط العالمية بالاضافة
والوفيات المؤكدة وما خفي كان
اعظم. فهل يجد العراقيون دواء
العامة هي ما لا يقل عن ست
وتسعين اصابة مؤكدة بالحمى
مع التهديدات الجديدة والتغيرات
العسكرية والاستراتيجية في
قواتها على الجبهات كافة.
والكرملين يعلن عن اعادة ترتيب
اعادت روسيا تموضع قواتها وردا
على المناورات الامريكية
بعد الان. ولا صوت يعلو فوق صوت
دوي المعارك. موسكو تستنفر
اوراقه بعد قرار انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى الناتو. فعلى الحدود
على حدودها الغربية. ها هي
المعدات الروسية لا ولن ترتاح
النظام سبب خوف الغرب من مواجهة
روسيا؟ بداية الرد. بدأت روسيا
اي اقل من ساعة واحدة. وحتى لو
لم يعد هناك احد ليشغل هذا
خبراء وناشطون ان النظام يمكنه
تدمير العالم في عشرات الدقائق
روجوزين ان صاروخ سارمات يستطيع
تدمير نصف ساحل قارة قد ترى
موسكو فيها تهديدا وفقا لروسيا
اليوم يا له من صاروخ مرعب. الرد
استبدال الوصف بالكيان
الاسرائيلي المحتل خلال المؤتمر
النظام فسيعمل بنفسه. يا له من
نظام مرعب حقا. هل يعد هذا
وضعها في حالة التأهب القتالية
خلال الخريف المقبل. وقال
ردها واعلن رئيس وكالة الفضاء
الروسية ديمتري دروجين ان صواريخ
سارمات الباليستية الاستراتيجية
القتالية العابرة للقارات سيتم
الروسي لم ينتهي. فبعدما رأت
موسكو التهديدات العسكرية تتصاعد
البسيطة ويعد من اكثر الاسلحة
سرية في العهد السوفيتي. ويقول
وهل بدأت اسرائيل الحرب على
سوريا ام انها مجرد هجمات عابرة؟
اي تدخل بشري. وبدون ان يستطيع
ان يوقفه كائن حي على وجه
الحمى النزفية تفتك بالعراق
والحالات في تزايد بشكل مرعب.
مسميات عدة لكنه النظام الروسي
وحده الذي سينهي العالم اليا دون
نهاية فيروس كورونا وبداية عصر
مرض خطير اخر؟ مصر تحت شعار معا
لنأكل مما نزرع. قطر تحاول فهل
يقبل الغرب وموسكو بواساطتها؟
والعالم قلق من وباء جديد بسبب
القرود. فهل يكتب هذا الوباء
تشاؤون. اذ يطلق عليها حلف
الناتو والخبراء العسكريون
بايدن يتعهد بحماية فنلندا فهل
يفي بوعده المرة وبعد الجزائر ها
هي العراق ترفض الكيان
الاسرائيلي. فمن التالي ولكن
بايدن وبريطانيا تتحدى روسيا في
مولدوفا فهل ترد موسكو على ذلك؟
يعلن بداية رد روسيا على انضمام
السويد وفنلندا الى الناتو وينشر
اثنتي عشرة وحدة قتالية. موسكو
تعلن دخول صواريخ الشيطان العابر
والتحركات العسكرية في نشاط
مستمر. ما هذا الذي يجري في
اليد الميتة. الة يوم القيامة.
ماكينة يوم القيامة سموها كما
اليد الميتة لروسيا جاهزة لضرب
جميع اعدائها. فهل على العالم ان
روسيا في هذه الفترة. يبتعد ثم
يطلب التفاوض فكيف سينتهي به
الحال. موسكو تحظر قرابة الف
امريكي من اراضيها من بينهم
للقارات الخدمة خلال الاشهر
المقبلة. التوترات تزداد
بعيدا عن امريكا التي لابد ان
تنتقم منها موسكو.
يخاف من ذلك? ولماذا كل هذا
الرعب من يد موسكو الميتة? بوتين